Let's motivate the graph partitioning
problem through a different problem.
Suppose I want to multiply a sparse
matrix A times a vector X.
Remember the duality between
matrices and graphs.
Meaning this sparse matrix has this
equivalent graph representation.
The rows and corresponding columns
of the matrix are vertices and
the non-zeros are edges.
One way to do a distributed breadth
first search is to use a computational
primitive that looks like this
linear algebra operation.
Now, suppose you decide to distribute
the work by first dividing the matrix
row-wise.
You would then assign
block rows to processes.
Note that this assignment corresponds
to a partitioning of the graph.
This example is a vertex based or
just vertex partition.
Observe that this partitioning
usually also implies
a partitioning of the vectors x and y.
That's because there's a one to one
mapping of vector entries to graph
vertices.
Now the amount of work in a sparse
matrix vector multiply is proportional
to the number of non-zeroes.
So, when you divide up the rows,
you might want to do so
in a way that balances the number
matrix non-zeroes per partition.
So that's one goal.
Now, you have another goal
in choosing a partition.
Hm, what is that goal?
Recall that the vertex x is partitioned.
Now suppose you want to
update the first block of Y.
Because of these non-zeros you're
going to need these corresponding
elements of x.
That requires communication with the
processes that own these elements of x.
In the language of graphs,
these communication exchanges happen
anytime an edge crosses
a process boundary.
For instance, these two non zeros,
correspond to this edge.
The two processes that own the endpoints
of the edge, will need to communicate.
This observation suggests a second goal.
To minimize communication volume,
you prefer to reduce
the number of edge cuts.
This example motivates the classic
graph partitioning problem.
You're given a graph and
a target number of partitions as input.
Your goal is to divide the vertices
into, say, P partitions.
You'd like this partitioning to
have the following properties.
First, these partitions should cover all
the vertices but should be disjoint.
The partition should also
be about equal in size.
And the number of cut
edges should be minimized.
That is the graph partitioning
problem in a nutshell.